sie renovieren sie putzen und sie
restaurieren mit hingabe im film das
große museum die menschen im
kunsthistorischen museum sind mit
stiller leidenschaft bei der sache
augenzwinkernd beobachtet vom regisseur
johannes holzhausen über ein jahr durfte
er in den hehren hallen filmen die er
von seinem studium der kunstgeschichte
hier bestens kannte dieses haus in dem
ich auch als student oft genug war
was mich eher ein gesprengt habe weil es
so mit seiner integrierten architektur
ja auch etwas einschüchtern deshalb
folgte dem etwas entgegen setzen wollte
das in gewissem sinne glaube ich
demokratisieren
also es mir wieder aneignen manchmal
scheint die zeit stillzustehen
doch langweilig wird es nie der film ist
bissig aber nie böse
im zentrum steht die liebevolle
beobachtung der oft skurril anmutende
tätigkeiten von menschen in einer sehr
eigenen welt das haus wird in schuss
gehalten etwa durch die jagd auf
schädlinge
der regisseur arbeitet ohne auf
kommentar ohne musik ohne interviews nur
eine devise gaga aus es gab eine fixe
regel das heißt die objekte werden nur
gezeigte mit ihnen etwas getan wird
ob da jetzt mit ihnen hantiert wird oder
darüber geredet wird es egal aber es
musste sein konflikt mitarbeitern im
riesen betrieb mit 400 angestellten war
es für das filmteam schwierig den
überblick über anfallende arbeiten und
termine zu behalten
ich war das ganze jahr in dem ich
gedreht habe geprägt von angst dass ich
etwas verpasse und man verpasst auch
ständig was weil es tatsächlich ständig
irgendetwas etwas passiert neben dem
sozialen biotop zeigt der film das
museum als staatstragende institution
welche das kaiserlich habsburgische erbe
pflegen muss und sich damit öfters
schwertut hause habe ich manchmal das
gefühl dass man die habsburger wie ein
klotz am bein hängen
das museum sei so holzhausen ein kultur
tanker ein frachtschiff aus der
vergangenheit
randvoll beladen und wie viel es ihnen
überhaupt in der sekunde holderied 1300
1300 ich wenn wir haben jetzt schon
längstens gestapelt nicht nur
platzmangel ist ein drängendes problem
das marketing ringt um eine moderne
präsentation des kultur frachtschiffes
die marken attribute wie wir sein wollen
stilvoll souverän berührend offen
das doch schön kann man überall hin
übertragen
ja ich glaube dass hinterfeld zahnpasta
holzhausens kamera führt ins verwinkelte
innerste macht verborgene sammlungen
zugänglich 150 stunden material hat er
gedreht ohne schaden anzurichten und
fast ohne sanaa
gedreht gedreht und dann alle hungrig
und so und dann wo haben sie in einer
hecke heimlich am schlusstag am montag
eine wurstsemmel verdrückt und das hat
kommt die sammlungsleiterin gesehen und
dies ausgerastet und so erfahren wir
auch wahnsinnig peinlich weil das war
sozusagen soeben da ist eine grenze
überschritten worden es gibt eben die
regeln darum mittel werden nicht
vertrieb im sammlungsbereich der wiener
institutionen film kommt nicht allein
über die londoner national gallery ist
ein ähnlicher film entstanden gedreht
vom amerikanischen dokumentarfilmer
frederik dokumentarfilme über museen ein
trend in der luft warum das so ist also
eine renaissance des museums vielleicht
hat natürlich was tragen des museums
sind zu säulen unserer kultur sind vor
oder fundamente im grunde im wahrsten
sinn des wortes ist da unser sind alle
unsere wurzeln
holzhausens kluger und witziger film
endet mit bruegels turmbau zu babel
sinnbild für vergebliches tun
vor allem aber für ein gebilde das nur
als gemeinschaftswerk funktioniert